the council I am councilor James Caston
chairman of mid-suffolk District Council
and I'll be chairing this meeting today
may I first remind you of some domestic
Arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water is also available from
the breakout area outside the meeting
room if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting by following
the fire exit signs and meet on the
Ipswich Town Football Club training
pitch do not re-enter the building until
you're told it's safe to do so please
switch off all mobile phones and or turn
them to silent and laptops please
I'd like to remind everyone present here
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there's confidential or exempt items if
you make a representation to this
meeting you will be deemed to buy the
council to have consented to been filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
and I'll move to the agenda
first item on the agenda is apologies
for absence
thank you chair
councilor Emma Rosen councilor Brewster
councilor Gould councilor e Byrne
councilor Guthrie councilor Phillips and
councilor Davies
thank you Declarations of interest from
counselors
are there any Declarations of Interest
no
right item three to confirm the minutes
of the meeting held on the 27th of
October for accuracy only does anyone
have any issues with accuracy
now could I get a proposal for those
minutes
counselor haddenham
and could I have a second to please
councilor Mueller
all those in favor will do this by show
of hands
that's carried thank you
item four is the um Chairman's
announcements I'll refer you to paper
mc227 for noting thank you
item five is leaders announcement and
I'd like to invite councilor Morley to
present her update for following this we
will have questions
um not just questions on Clarity but
questions on things within the leaders
announcements
thank you thank you Jeff
the death of two-year-old AWA bishek
after exposure to mold in his family's
flat in Rochdale was a tragedy
and I am sure that all members will join
me in expressing our sympathies to his
family
this sad case has rightly put the
standard of social housing in the
spotlight
in the last week housing secretary
Michael Gove has written to all housing
providers in England including baber and
mid-suffolk councils calling for an
urgent assessment of homes to provide
reassurance over standards
but we didn't wait for this government
letter in order to act we had already
begun initiating work to address this
members will be aware that we initiated
a full diagnostic review of Building
Services earlier in the year
this picked up on the need to increase
our input into resolving issues around
mold and damp and we have acted on those
recommendations
this year for example we have trained
more people to deliver damp and mold
treatment and employed a damp specialist
surveyor we're also recruiting another
surveyor to increase capacity
the well-being of our tenants has always
been a priority and following this case
I can promise members that we will
redouble our efforts to ensure the
quality of all our homes so that such a
tragedy cannot happen here
I've spoken to our new housing director
Deborah Fenton
who has updated me on the actions
already taken this year to resolve any
damp and mold issues and further
measures are planned
we're also progressing well with our
stock condition survey and our
developing and costing a retrofit
program
the housing directorate will also be
developing a performance framework to be
presented to cabinets and the Tenant
board every quarter helping both members
and tenants hold us to account
this work is just a part of what we're
doing to ensure our homes are fit full
of future
since our last full council meeting and
historic County deal for Suffolk has
been announced by Chancellor Jeremy Hunt
this is the first County deal of its
kind in the country and if agreed we'll
deliver Decades of significant
additional investment into local
priorities
it will give Suffolk greater
decision-making Powers around the likes
of Transport infrastructure and skills
as you know Suffolk public sector
leaders including from mid-sufficient
labor and rmps have been working
collaboratively on this for some time
it has been a great example of Suffolk
working together for the benefit of
residents and businesses
the chancellor said Suffolk would get a
directly elected mayor but I want to
clarify that Suffolk is actually
pursuing a model where the leader of cat
Suffolk County Council is directly
elected by the people of Suffolk it will
not be an elected mayor and the current
leader cabinet model will be retained
post change would not add any new levels
of bureaucracy nor create any new
offices
I will keep you informed about the
county deal as it progresses
next week mid-suffolk District Council
will publish our end of term report
this report tells the story of our
council's fantastic achievements in the
last four years
it covers the full breadth of what we
have done from how we have supported
many thousands of residents and
businesses during the covid-19 pandemic
to how we are now helping in the cost of
living crisis
but he's not just about how we have
magnificently stepped up to the
challenges we have faced
it is a celebration of the outstanding
work done by the council in all areas
including planning and housing driving
economic growth and delivering a vision
for our district and its communities
I would urge everyone to read it as soon
as it's published reflect on our
achievements and feel pride in what we
do
and please share it with people and
parishes in your ward
thank you Jeff
thank you very much councilor Morley do
we have any questions councilor wellum
thank you chair
um I'm really pleased that a check is
being carried out the damp within the
homes that we look after
um councilor had him and I now one
instance where
damage to a roof was reported in
February
and when I eventually it was eventually
told of it it was reported many times to
housing nothing was done
eventually I managed to get through to
somebody who repaired the roof but they
did not look in the roof space
the first repair that was done was not
to the roof it was to lay a polythene
sheet in the roof space
nobody has checked
that
the um
The Loft insulation is wet nor have they
done anything about it
so yeah you might know that yeah you've
got you've got these checks going on but
we have seen the photographs of The Damp
coming through from the wet Loft
insulation can you please ensure
something's done about it
Council morning
yes
I had hoped to be able to introduce our
new director of housing to you all
tonight
um Deborah Fenton
our new director has been in place for
just over a week
and I'd like to give her time to get to
grips with all the figures and also the
people in her department so
um while I can't answer your direct
question
or is your specific question on that
um we will be preparing a briefing paper
to go out once once Deborah has
clarified all the issues
thank you councilor geek
damper caused by allergic reactions to
spores and that kind of thing
um can I ask whether the treatments are
going to Center on structural issues and
on heating issues to address the root
causes of the problem and are not just
going to be chemical treatments to kill
the mold because allergic reactions to
those chemical treatments can be just as
bad and they don't treat the root cause
Council Morley
that gets into the more detail
thank you councilor field
thank you a question really
um
to back up what council Wellen was
saying and where I regularly attend a
sheltered accommodation
because we're running a club there but
there's an individual there who has
significant disabilities who had roof
leaking it's at least a year ago I think
it's actually two but at least a year
ago as variously been told repair and
it's too expensive for the council to to
consider a very similar solution
solution to the one that was mentioned
was put in place something in a membrane
in the roof space it subsequently a
couple of weeks ago when it reported
rained again and we're subjecting a
person who has you know very substantial
disabilities and things to to an
appalling life so it's just seeking
again the assurance that
stand there will be a dress to it's all
issues of you know outstanding
maintenance of that type and
particularly this is an area where to
clearly walk the scheme manager contacts
the council regularly and he gets
absolutely nowhere with pushing forward
repairs
thank you and the councilor haddenham
has offered to take this question as
that's her particular area so councilor
had in them
sorry just I mean
sorry councilor Morley
no um we we're just going to leave that
to councilor Morley thank you
as soon as we have details on the detail
that you're seeking we will publish it
for you
thank you councilor rotten
we're all tragic to hear the news of a
child who actually died but there was
another child who was
very very seriously ill as a result of
mold within its accommodation
but
his problems were actually exacerbated
by the company trying to resolve the
mold problem and using chemicals to
actually spray the house
of course the child then reacted very
badly to those chemicals and ended up
very very seriously ill in hospital and
I'd like the Assurance of the housing
cabinet portfolio holder that no
chemicals will be used in any of those
properties where this work needs to be
done thank you
thank you very much I refer the
counselor to my previous announcement
when the previous response wouldn't we
uh
I'm not going to answer questions on
every single person in the district
when we've got the detail we'll share it
thank you very much and I can't see
anything
councilor scarf
thank you I mean it's relating to this
to the same issue but a slightly
different context
um
we heard on Monday actually a scrutiny
committee about the work that CA do
um and the problems with uh the cost of
living which is directly related to us
as well and he
and he sometimes the problem is it's
lack of suitable ventilation the
inability to afford the heating in order
to keep the mold at Bay or keep the
condensation at Bay so can the leader
give us some assurance that when our
staff go and look at the issue they look
at it holistically and perhaps if
there's something they can do with the
obviously with the permission of the
tenant maybe they can put them in touch
with CA in terms of advice they might be
able to apply for heating vouchers which
CA hand out basically can we have an
holistic approach because it's not just
a silo approach in terms of this issue
it's a it's a bigger issue and they may
be able to give some practical advice
and some help which might actually
long-term more eliminate the problem
than trying to cure the mold in the
first place
just at this point I'd say that we're
straying into um councilor hadnam's
portfolio here and she's not able to
answer questions on Leader's
announcements so if um if you do have
any further questions could you email
them to um councilor hand them the
portfolio holder please and um I'll move
on thank you
so item six to receive notifications of
petitions according in accordance with
Council procedure rules
thank you chair none received
thank you very much and item seven
questions by the public in accordance
with the council procedure rules I refer
you to the questions in the tabled
papers and I would like to invite
councilor um Mr Pyle sorry
um to ask his question please um please
step up Mr Pyle
thank you chairman I've had a promotion
already have I I appreciate that
um
during a settle stand
please whatever you're comfortable with
but yeah I'll stand so thank you very
much the opportunity tonight to ask a
question given that on the 9th of
November 2022 a development control
committee refused permission for a
single house in elmswell because it was
to be built on public open space how is
it possible that mid-suffolk cabinet
continued to plan for 50 houses on nine
acres of public open space on the other
side of the village
thank you Mr Paul now um councilor Gould
is not here for because of ill health
but um councilor Richardson has um
offered to um Step In so councilor
Richardson
thank you chair and thank you Mr Pyle
for your question
um I'm not party to the specifics of the
case uh that you refer to although I am
reliably informed at the planning
committee report concluded that
information insufficient uh information
had been provided by the applicant in
that case to determine whether the
proposal accorded uh with the national
planning policy framework as each
planning case is determined on its own
merits um I don't think it's appropriate
to compare sites in this way
um particularly is the formal status of
these sites uh differs within our
emerging local plan
um
as members will be aware the council is
considering the delivery of an exempt
class sustainable residential
development in elmswell of approximately
50 homes on a site within the council's
ownership at church and school roads and
though it is still in its early days in
terms of shaping this proposal further
the First Community engagement event
took place last week which provided
significant feedback for further
consideration and we are very grateful
for the high level of attendance and
engagement from the community within
elmswell and there will be further
engagement in this regard and any scheme
we're causing in due course be
considered by the planning Authority and
assessed accordingly
teacher thank you councilor Richardson
um Mr Pyle do you have a supplementary
question
given the positive discussions with
elmswell Parish Council about the
possibility of a new Primary School on
the site why is this auction being
dropped
councilor Richardson thank you very much
chair and to this matter of the question
of a primary school has been discussed
at cabinet
um both early this month and I think
last year as well the issue being and
members will be aware of the
difficulties associated with HRA
ownership of land but for the for the
for Simplicity the actual site itself is
owned by the housing revenue account
which for legal reasons is a separate
ring fenced entity for Mid suffix
otherwise general fund what this means
in practice is that for any disposal of
the land for the purposes not
um for housing purposes we would need to
prove that there was no way the land
could facilitate
and there was no need for housing within
a particular area now given that
elsewhere is designated as a core
village within our emerging local plan
given that it's a highly sustainable
Village given the amenities that are
present given the fact it's got
excellent transport connections we kind
of cannot provides of those two criteria
and the decision ultimately would have
to go to the Secretary of State for
approval provided we didn't meet either
those conditions and
care instance
we can't prove that we don't think we'll
get the Secretary of State's approval
for that disposal of the land so whilst
we've had extensive conversations with
local stakeholders the approach that
we've taken and that's the advice that
we as cabin have receive from officers
is
follow the delivery of housing there is
a need for particularly affordable
housing within elmsworld in the local
area and for that reason cabinets
indication earlier this month was that
we wish to proceed with housing for that
site
thank you chair thank you and I'd like
to thank Mr Paul for coming in and
asking this question and thank councilor
Richardson for stepping in for Council
of gold to answer it and we'll move on
to item eight questions by councils in
accordance with the council procedure
rules I refer you to the questions in
the table papers and I'd like to invite
councilman to ask his question
thank you chair
um councilor Morley as as leader of the
council has welcomed the announcement of
a Devolution deal for Suffolk with a
directly elected Council leader
what level of involvement will other
counselors in this Authority have in
agreeing this change to suffolk's
governance thank you
thank you thank you that question for
councilor Morley
thank you councilman
um any change to a directly elected
leader philosopher County Council is a
governance change for Suffolk County
Council and mid-suffolk District Council
would not be involved in that
you councilor Molly
um
councilman do you have a supplementary
question
which one do I choose um
does she agree that there is a lack of
clarity in the current information in
the public domain about how this new
role will work
thank you councilor Morley would you
like to respond
yes I do
thank you
and the next item is counselor
appointments are there any changes to
places
no no
thank you and so we go to item 10 which
is motions on notice to consider the
Motions on notice received from
councilor Morley
so um councilor Morley would you like to
move your motion
thank you Jeff
um this motion is a template that
councils and councils can use to
publicly demonstrate their commitment to
improving the quality of public and
political debate and challenging abuse
and intimidation of people in public
life
by signing up to the LGA debate not hate
campaign
councils that have passed such a motion
should email
and the email address that's listed in
the papers is actually misspelled it
should say debate not hate rather than
Note hate at local.gov dot UK
to be added to the list of public
organizations supporting the campaign
councils who've signed up will receive
more information on how councils can
support the campaign and improve support
for councilors in their local areas
and counselors can also find more
information on the debate not hate
campaign website
the intimidation and abuse of counselors
in person or otherwise undermines
democracy
preventing electric members from
representing the communities they serve
deterring individuals from standing for
election and undermining public life in
Democratic processes
this Council notes that increasing
levels of toxicity in public and
political discourse is having a
detrimental impact on local democracy
and that prevention support and
responses to abuse and intimidation
of local politicians must improve to
ensure counselors feel safe and able to
continue representing their residents
this Council therefore commits challenge
the normalization of abuse against
councilors and uphold exemplary
standards of public and political debate
in all it does
the council further agrees to sign up to
the lga's debate not hate campaign
this campaign aims to raise public
awareness of the role of councilors in
local communities encourage healthy
debate and improve the response to and
support for local politicians facing
abuse and intimidation
in addition this Council resolves to
write to our local members of parliament
to ask them to support the campaign
a right to the government to ask them to
work with the LGA
to develop and Implement a plan to
address abuse and intimidation of
politicians
regularly review the support available
to councilors in relation to abuse and
intimidation and counselor safety
and work with the local police to ensure
there is a clear and joined up mechanism
for reporting threats and other concerns
about the safety of councilors and their
families
and we should also take a zero tolerance
approach to the abuse of counselors and
officers
but yeah I'll call for a second
very much and I think councilor mellons
got his name down to secondness
councilman
yeah I'm happy to see second this and
I'll speak now if that's okay okay yes
please
so I was very pleased when councilor
Morley asked me to Second this motion
a few weeks ago I went to an LGA events
in London and as part of the day we
heard a presentation about this debate
not hate initiative
seems to be the case with all LGA events
I came away with a load of useful
information and covid
but having recovered from that I'm
pleased to have this early opportunity
to endorse this very worthwhile
campaign
I was thinking about over the
three and a half years I've been a
district councilor and a few years
before that as a parish counselor and I
couldn't really think of many occasions
when I had received a boost or
intimidation though I have been at a few
meetings where feelings have run high
but when I started to widen that out and
think about people that I know I soon
came up with some very sad and worrying
examples you don't have to look very far
now as I'm sure we're all aware
councilor John Ward the leader of baber
had a campaign of intimidation focused
on him with a group of people even
coming to his home and causing alarm and
distress to his family which was a
totally unacceptable situation I was
very glad to see that the police took it
seriously
another example I thought of is some
counselor colleagues in beckles
during the first covid lockdown in a bid
to keep the local economy working they
arranged to set up separation barriers
for safe queuing in the Town Center what
was a very laudable initiative but not
everyone agreed with it and there were
some downsides in terms of vehicle
movements but what ensued from that was
was a ferocious campaign against those
two councilors they would belittled they
were threatened and their families
suffered intimidation which ended up
with the police being involved and these
two two councilors were advised to stay
locked in at home for two weeks and one
of them has even moved away from the
area as a result so again totally
unacceptable behavior from a vocal
minority who weren't prepared to use the
proper channels of debate but just
wanted to achieve their aims by any
means
and the third example I thought of is my
older brother David as some of you know
he's the leader of Nottingham City
Council and he served that Community as
a counselor and his leader for about 20
years now
but it's unfortunately had to make some
very tough choices as leader service
cuts and that sort of thing
but the level of criticism and vitriol
and abuse he receives is is truly
appalling I don't know how he handles it
these are just three examples I thought
of but all three encouraged me to
support this motion and encourage my
colleagues to do so too if we want more
people to stand as counselors and serve
their communities we need to call out
these sort of behaviors whenever we see
them
but I'll finish on a more positive note
this motion talks about committing
ourselves to upholding exemplary
standards of public and political debate
and I think in this Council we generally
do and I very much appreciate that you
know we disagree and sometimes we
strongly disagree and the debate can be
robust
you know we as an opposition have been
critical of some of the decisions the
Administration has taken and you've been
critical of our stance at other times
but in the main that debate has been
civil it's been polite it's been
courteous and we shouldn't take that for
granted we should continue to aim high
no doubt we will continue to disagree on
some issues but on this motion I think
we can come together to support it thank
you
thank you councilman and at the end of
the um debate if you wish to say
anything more I'll I'll allow that
um so um
so I'd like to go to debate and um each
councilor will be able to speak for once
for no more than three minutes and the
first person is councilor parcel
and thanks very much um chairman well
just a few comments I I've got no
hesitation in supporting this motion and
uh just a few Reflections I suppose
um I think democracy the opportunity for
us all to vote in elections or whatever
they are is something that we should
cherish sadly in society too many people
don't recognize that every single one of
us here has a democratic mandate and I
think that's important because that's
the way we work in this country and I
think was it Churchill said our system
or words that effect isn't very good the
trouble is everything else is worse
now there is no perfect system we could
discuss that but I would agree with you
Andrew and Susie the debate we have here
is civilized
um and that's how it should be you agree
to differ you put your differences in
The Ballot Box or whether it is but just
reflect
what happens in places like Russia China
other dictatorial regimes where there is
no chance for anybody to vote at all you
can vote this way as long as you do as
you're told well that isn't the way we
work and despite the difficulties
challenges we all have Etc in this
country going back for many years I
think our system has served us pretty
well and I think that's something we
need to to look after
there are difficult decisions you'll you
always have to make in any elected
position doesn't matter what level it is
um the art of good communication of
course is important but I do detect
there is a somewhat unpleasant tenor for
the things that people say and
particularly on social media where you
can hide away because of you frankly in
some cases they've got the guts to stand
up and say it properly in a civilized
way I can think of other councils not
very far from here where there's
bringing some pretty poisonous Comet
which is uncalled for I'm not going to
name them
I could actually suggest that some of
that is almost akin to a hate crime
there is no place in our society for
hate crime of any description be it
about sexuality gender political beliefs
I mean I could go on and on and on and
we do need to try and take a lead to
stop that and the first way we can do
that is here in this chamber which I
honestly do think happens
um if I can go back nearly 20 years like
some others one or two over there have
been there even longer than that but
generally speaking and that's more than
just generally speaking actually debates
would be good we've agreed to differ you
have a vote and you move forward in that
way so I think we've got to look at the
positives and do what we can to persuade
people this is how to behave and it
doesn't matter if we disagree we can
have vigorous debates as long as it's
courteous and I think that's what this
Council does particularly well so where
was unto all involved and I shall
certainly be voting for this thank you
very much
thank you chair
um well I'm pleased to say I had the
opportunity to sign my support for for
the LGA campaign at the LGA conference
in July and so there's no doubt about
where I stand on it what I want to just
say that it would be good to see on
behalf of the council is a more active
role on the part of our Communications
team
um particularly in the um in the Social
Media Forum and
um you know at the minimum
to see factual Corrections coming
forward and
um and where where there is abuse
um
there should be some defense of members
um I'm
a thick-skinned and ugly as anybody and
and I post
personally in my own name and and I
think that's that's as it should be and
it's right but when I I do react is when
I see um quite a clear implications of
of corruption
um you know brown paper on blopes etc
etc when I have already posted about
planning decision which people are
debating and I and I've I've been on the
committee that day and you know you know
something that's incorrect In what's
been said or whatever people unders to
help people understand why the decision
things like that I will I will post and
when I see the abuse then I get very
unhappy about it and I really do think
that there is a role for our
Communications Department in as I said
factual correction and certainly to
reject implications of corruption either
on the part of officers or members alike
thank you very much councilor Richardson
thank you very much chair
um I'll start with a small
um book which I will address
um because sometimes I feel a little bit
skeptical
um about debating motions or business
within the council that primarily
affects us as counselors
for fear of being perceived as being
self-indulgent
um but I don't think that on this
occasion because I think there is a uh
well a couple of really serious
principles that we are considering as
part of this motion the first is simple
I think I'm objectionable
um that anyone should be free to go
about their business uh without
um or indeed their lives without fear of
intimidation or abuse
um secondly
didn't know elected official or a
representative should be subject to
violence designed to prevent them from
discharging their obligations to
to as others have already said and I
totally agree with councilor Mellon and
councilor Passmore
um that in this chamber I think and as
councilors we always conduct ourselves
in a
manner and but frankly I don't think
that matters in a way the small elephant
in the room and I know we're not as
notorious or as prominent as members of
parliament but the two people that I
think government discussing this debate
are Joe Cox and David Amos who are both
killed doing the jobs that they love and
frankly we all agree we're thoroughly
decent people
um
but who were murdered nonetheless
um and so I think we should be therefore
very clear
um that we will never tolerate hate the
public life and should oppose it at
every turn I think it's as simple as
that I think it's a powerful statement
we can make as a council and for that
reason I will be wholeheartedly
supporting this nation and commend
Council Morley and councilman for
bringing it before us this evening thank
you chair
[Music]
thank you chair so far we've mainly
talked about what goes on in this
chamber
um I've had experience as a parish
counselor of what I I wouldn't have
thought of it as a hate campaign but now
having heard this discussion I've
realized it was two people came to my
house to say they wanted to discuss one
thing and they turned against me and
because really they're what they wanted
to talk about was something completely
different and I've seen it in other I
mean still Upland I I know it's a pretty
rough place to live but
I would not you know I would not have I
would not have expected it there and now
I see that it does you know it does take
place at Parish Council level so I think
this applies to parish councils and I
think it's important that we remember
that and if there is an opportunity
through our Communications people to let
Parish councils know about it I think
that is important and I will be
supporting you thank you chair
thank you chair I'd like to add my voice
to everybody who's spoken so far and
just also to say that I think it's
really crucial that we try to encourage
more people and a more diverse set of
people into standing for election and we
often see
very conspicuous examples of of hate and
of violence and of intimidation and if
we can redress that slightly by having a
very conspicuous
to to to address that with the debate
not hate campaign if we can join that in
a very conspicuous way and talk about
how we are addressing it I'm sure that
will be helpful in attracting more
people to to stand for election to this
fabulous chamber
thank you very much any further
contributions
Council the melon you don't have to say
anything at this point but um you're
welcome to before I go to councilor
Morley
the things then quickly um
I'm not on Twitter I know some
councilors are but I do kind of keep a
weather eye on local social media and
and sadly you know even on local
Facebook pages and Community forums you
do see
counselors and officers and the council
occasionally being denigrated and
criticized quite often for things over
which we have no control or
responsibility
appreciate councilor mathison's point
and I do myself sometimes try to set the
record straight but it can be an uphill
battle
I just want to mention too of course I
hadn't really mentioned this previously
the last point of the the motion does
talk about
a zero tolerance approach to abuse of
counselors and officers that both are
included we shouldn't tolerate any kind
of
intimidation against officers too
I think we just need to um perhaps amend
the first point of the uh the motion
where it says we're going to write to
our local Member of Parliament because I
think there's at least two and
eventually there might be three
um covering mid-suffolk um that but
that's the only very minor thing we
perhaps need to amend and I'm certainly
happy that there seems to be uh support
for this motion across the house thank
you
thank you very much and um councilor
Morley do you have anything to add
just reflecting on some of the things
that have been said
in the main I have not really
experienced much in the way of abuse
there have been a few a couple of
instances once where
um I was visiting a resident
and somebody came and parked outside to
intimidate me and then I went I walked
to
the property next door to speak to them
and they followed me and drove to the
property next door and sat outside till
I came out and then when I came out
there and went walked to the post office
they followed me all the way behind me
going to the post office so
um
and that makes it really difficult for
me to support my residents and so that
type of behavior is just not acceptable
it's only happened once but in the main
the main abuse that occurs I find is
online
and it's generally it's not the forums
where we as a council are present it's
some of the other social media sites
like next door for instance where
um
being helpful as I am I post comments
occasionally not very often
um
but the abuse that you get
is a really big deterrent and so if
residents are posting about where can I
find this how can I get help on that and
I am intimidated into not responding
then that is a really big issue
and
being the sensitive soul that I am I
have occasionally not responded and I've
it upsets me and it hurts me
that I am placed in that position
because of some
people who don't know how to behave so
I together with John counselor John Ward
when we were at the LGA we both signed
up to this campaign back in July at the
LGA conference
we've signed as individuals I would
encourage every counselor in this room
to sign up as individuals because as
well as signing up as a district council
signing up as individuals greatly
increases the greatly enhances our
message that we're sending out to
everybody
so thank you all for the positive
comments that you've all made
and I look forward to progressing this
these things
um when I in response to councilor
mellon's point about
plurals in terms of our MPS when I read
out the statement I did refer to members
of parliament because I did notice that
that slight
irregularity there so thank you all
everybody very much for supporting this
thank you very much for that and thank
you everyone that contributed and
there's some quite personal
contributions there and um thank you for
that so um we'll now um go to the boat
for this motion I will ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct an electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for councilors to cast their
vote
cancer Pat can I take your vote
thank you
chair that's unanimous that's 27 votes
for
thank you very much
[Applause]
so that's carried so we'll now go on to
the second motion of the night
um to consider the motion from councilor
Mellon councilman would you like to move
your motion
yeah thank you chip
I'm sure that all counselors are aware
that we have a problem with water
quality in this country and mid-suffolk
is not exempt from this problem
to be widely reported in the national
press with some alarming reports of
river pollution and beaches being closed
due to the danger to swimmers and even
if this morning if you're listening to
the today program at five to nine they
were discussing a report that's been
published today by Surfers against
sewage on this very issue
we don't have many Surfers in this stuff
but we do still have a problem and the
problem seems to be this
in periods of rainfall and not just in
heavy rainfall
treatment works can become overwhelmed
with the volume of surface water coming
in
and in these circumstances treatment
works have what is effectively a safety
valve something called a combined storm
overflow a CSO where excess water can be
released
and unfortunately since they receive
surface water together with everything
else they don't discharge clean water
and so these storm overflows contain
partly raw sewage untreated which is
discharged direct into the local
Watercourse
well how do we know this well we know it
because the water treatment companies
and here it's anglian water have to
monitor these overflows and publish the
figures
and I've included in the motion wording
a table showing four sites from across
the district with anglian water's own
figures from last year
this is not the full picture but at
least it is an indication of the problem
now I'm not saying that anglian water is
pumping out raw undiluted sewage on all
these occasions for all these hours but
a combined storm overflow is exactly
there combined surface water and sewage
and clearly this is not just happening
in extreme storm events but much more
often
treatment sites unable to cope on a
regular basis
so this is the problem
and it's a problem for the environment
with often severe effects on the
ecosystems down without going into the
details of excess nutrients biological
oxygen demand and so on I think we can
understand there's a problem there but
it's also a health risk for people who
use the rivers you know whether it's
fishermen kayakers paddle boarders or
increasingly wild swimmers
yes people do swim in our rivers or in
the rivers that flow out of mid-suffolk
it's been a huge interest in wild
swimming in the last few years there are
lots of benefits to physical and mental
health
but clearly they are somewhat undermined
if you pick up the E coli while you're
doing it
so whilst I'm not recommending swimming
in water which has not been being
declared safe for bathing we know that
it happens
so what role does the council play in
all this and how will this motion help
I think firstly we can play our part by
publicly scrutinizing this problem so
the first part of the motion asks our
scrutiny committee to take a look
inviting representatives from the
various bodies that are involved and
question them so that we can understand
the scale of the problem and what is
already being done to address it
and secondly we have a role because we
are the local planning Authority and
through our planning process and through
our local plan we end up giving
permission for hundreds of new homes
each year
more homes means more people and as
surely as night follows day this means
increased volumes of sewage requiring
treatment
now angling water is the only provider
of water treatment yeah
works and basically has to take this
extra sewage it's what we call the duty
to connect and this is really the number
of the problem so when we have a major
development and Anglia water is asked as
a statutory consultee to respond they
have a kind of standard answer angler
water has the network capacity to take
flows from this development
but what they're saying is basically you
know the pipes can take it
but actually what we really need to know
is can they treat it or you know are
these 50 homes or 85 ohms or 150 homes
going to end up contributing to storm
overflows discharging untreated sewage
so this motion proposes a small tweak to
our planning procedure when an
application for a major development
comes in we want just a little bit more
information from angling water than they
currently provide and this is the third
paragraph of the motion we would like to
know which treatment works will be
managing the sewage what is the capacity
receive that facility to treat the
additional volumes and whether the
increased volume will increase
discharges of untreated sewage
now we cannot force angling water to
provide this information but
we can ask
clearly it would be an angling Waters
interested to provide the information
where it can
now further to this in paragraph four of
the motion we're asking that planning
officers when they prepare a report for
major applications those that come to
planning committee they include in that
report a specific section on the on the
potential
of the development to contribute to
discharges of untreated sewage or to
report back
on the information received or not
received
let me just State briefly what this
motion is not about it is not seeking to
create planning policy by Council motion
nor is it seeking to make this issue a
material consideration because under
planning law currently it can't be
so we're not seeking to use this issue
to frustrate development
and for example if a planning committee
member proposed refusal of an
application on the basis that it would
increase discharges of sewage our senior
planning officers would make it very
clear that that is not
possible reason
officers have highlighted to me where
the planning inspector have overturned
refusals of that kind
so what would this motion achieve this
is I believe I think an area where where
there's a gap in the information
clear information is is harming the
public interest
to be examined in the clear light of day
we need all the stakeholders in this to
share what they are doing to combat this
problem I think scrutiny is a good place
to do this and we un need to understand
clearly what the impact of new
development is contributing to the
problem and I believe the minor change
that I propose to our planning procedure
that will help to Spotlight this issue
I'm happy to propose this motion and I'm
grateful to council Fleming for her
input in formulating it and for agreeing
to Second it thank you Chad
thank you very much councilor Fleming
for raising the issue and for offering
me the opportunity to Second it
um so I welcome and endorse the motion
and um
I'm very pleased to be able to comment
um particularly as I also chair the
Suffolk flood risk
um scrutiny committee where we've been
looking at water quality as well as
actual flooding we've actually added
water quality to our terms of reference
and I think that's an important step as
well
you're probably aware that in Suffolk
and in mid-suffolk none of our surface
water rivers or streams are in classed
as good they are all
um poor or moderate in their water
quality condition which is monitored by
the environment agency I'm just going to
touch on the gipping catchment as an
example and then say something augments
what my colleague has said about what
mid-suffolk can possibly do to help the
general discontent I might add among the
public
about poor water quality is enormous
and growing the dipping discharges to
the Orwell Estuary this is a a ramsar
site it's a special protection area and
a triple SI and it supports rare birds
in nationally significant numbers
the gipping is under high pressure also
for amenity fishing and Recreation by
people
but it is classed to poor ecological
status due mainly to phosphate and
oxygen depletion
but it also fails for several newly
listed chemical persistent and
biologically accumulative pollutants
pollutant sources such as wastewater
treatment plants which in this case
operated by anglian water such as at
Stone Market in Needham market and
contribute as well as industry and
agriculture the waving is another
important river in mid-suffolk
and this is a beautiful River Rising
near Redgrave passes through the lopham
fen triple SI
onto this and Hudson whereas joined by
the river dove
discharges of untreated sewerage during
heavy rainfall
combined to overflow the storm system
and as my colleague has said
under the current regime are released
untreated and this happens frequently
and I may add also exceed the
um
allowable number of discharges that the
environment agency tolerates and the
environment agency I know an anglian
water are working together to try and
resolve this situation but without major
investment and a change in the
legislature
there is a limit to what can be done
currently developers as have been said
have an automatic right to connect
however
legislation under the environment act
flood and Water Management act sorry
would change that and this is something
that I think this Council
can try to lobby for
some of the changes of schedule 3 of The
Water Management act would mean that the
automatic right to connect that
developers currently have would be
removed
um
it would also mandate implementation of
sustainable drainage for all new
developments
and ensure surface water is managed in a
sustainable manner it will ensure that
sustainable drainage on new developments
are adopted properly and this is
something that where the planning system
can help and this would secure the
long-term maintenance of these features
which are frequently failing and
currently we have concerns about
long-term maintenance of suds
and fourthly studs on new developments
must be constructed to the current
standards currently is this is not a
function of the lead local flood
Authority and planning authorities do
not have the resource of expertise to
undertake the work so having proper
adoption and a long-term plan will do a
lot to help but what can this district
council do
we've already mentioned some of the
things and dialogue with anglian water
is the starting point but until the
legislation mentioned is formalized
there are things we can do to implement
this deferest storm water overflows
discharge reduction gland which you can
look up on the internet it was released
this summer
we can work with developers to update
our design guide to bring into that
design guide the criteria in in the
discharge reduction plan
we can designate New River bathing sites
to give local communities the tools they
need because once the site is designated
as a bathing site it gives extra
tools to communities to work with the
environment agency and clean it up and
monitor it and um
we can also engage with anglian water as
statutory conscious salties on planning
applications
in other words there is a lot we can do
and it largely involves planning and um
in conclusion this motion reflects our
concerns about water quality it
recognizes our responsibility to act
where we possibly can do so clean water
can and will be treated as a higher
priority in Council programs than ever
before thank you
[Applause]
thank you councilor Fleming and there
will be an opportunity to speak again at
the end of debate should you um want it
so um I'll move on to debate the same
rules for debate as before three minutes
and one contribution please and the
first person to speak will be counselor
twice in one night thank you very much
Mr chairman sir just a few comments I
I'm I'm going to support this motion I
don't have a problem with that because I
do think that looking after our Water
Resource is far better is really really
crucial
it's a precious resource and far too
many people generally you know the UK
take it for granted and we need to have
a bit of a mindset here to change that
and so anything we can do to reduce
sewage discharge of course has to be
welcomed
um Matthew and others on planning a will
know I've in just about every single
case see where there's a major
development can we not do something to
stop this obsession with concreting over
hard surfaces for driveways and
everything else minimize it so the water
percolates into the groundwater because
if we don't do sort to do something
about that it will act as a serious
constraint on economic development
housing growth for young people and all
sorts of things so now is the time to
look at what else could we do now I'm
not an expert fortunately on planning
policy but it does get my goat the fact
that there seems to be a real difficulty
with trying to put things like that on
as conditions so in addition I do think
that's something to look at that doesn't
obviate the need to have this motion
because I quite agree with it and the
other thing I'm always puzzled about we
live in the driest part of the country
why is it that when we have larger
States designed from now on
why do we actually mix up sewage and
storm water drainage water it can't be
beyond the wit of man to actually find a
dual system as part of something we
should be doing going forwards so if we
add more water to percolate into the
groundwater system where most of our
water actually comes from the borehole
in the chalk aquifer that would be
really good and the other thing just
picking up on Jessica's point about some
of the rivers we've got some fantastic
rivers in mid-suffolk they may not be as
big as some other areas but if you look
for example the wrap the gipping the
Dove Valley not far from where I live
and I did of course think about this on
the I had to go with the lower stuff
today and so I went along the a143 going
up to Beccles and I did travel into
Norfolk
because that's where the road is and
looked over that beautiful wavely Valley
and I thought thank God I can see it
from an inferior place and look at how
beautiful it is I know I'm pretty
everybody's leg here
um looking at it from Norfolk into
Suffolk it is a real jewel in the crown
you go there in summer with the um late
Springers the leaves are coming out that
glorious mixture of green and everything
else you look at the wildlife the
English Longhorn cattle grazing on The
Meadows there that's something that
danwell needs to be looked after and I
do think water resources are fundamental
there so anything we can do to improve
on that you can definitely Count Me In
and I'd love it in future if we can look
at what we can do with our planning
policy Now isn't
debate it but there are some pretty
obvious Common Sense things that we
could do but sadly because of national
legislation Common Sense doesn't often
pervade in what we need to do thank you
very much
thank you councilor Passmore and that
was absolutely perfect timing to the the
exact second of the three minutes
so um thank you very much councilor
Richardson
thank you very much chair um a few
comments to make on this motion although
I can't guarantee I'll be as perfect as
councilor Passmore in his timing but
I'll do my best
um firstly just as a general comment I
have a great sympathy with with I think
what this motion is fundamentally trying
to achieve and I again agree with the
premise of I think what the mission is
getting to the last status as the local
planning Authority does give us the
opportunity to influence areas that
don't fall under our sort of direct
statutory control and still funding and
the opportunities to improve
infrastructure is is a perfect example
of that
um but I do think and I I wish to sort
of emphasize this point that the caveat
of the councilor melon added in his
introduction
um is especially important that we must
remind ourselves and must stress
um that what we're considering in terms
of changes to the planning system
does not mean that water quality or
anything we're considering here would
then be a material consideration for
refuse on your planning application and
of course ultimately it would be for the
regulator off what rather than
mid-suffolk
and to ensure that our water supply is
safe and sustainable
and so for that reason and obviously I
stressed out but considering the merits
of this
um a motion I
reason to oppose it
I think we really should sort of
emphasize that last point of the week as
counselors as a council entity I've
always had the view that we shouldn't be
in a position where we're over promising
and under delivering
um so I think it's it's right that we
stress that we are responsible for
versus what we're not responsible for
um but that doesn't prevent me from
supporting this motion here only sort of
aspect I might like to see clarified or
changed and and
the charm in your hands and with the
proposal and second of the the motion
whether you'd like this as a formal
Amendment or just as an informal
suggestion but I think in addition to
any proposed changes to the planning
system I also think it's worthwhile
again similar to the previous motion
writing to rmps writing to off what to
express our concern and express our
desire to desire to see water quality
improved because as has been referenced
we have only limited levers to influence
and
and actually what influence we can bring
to bear on those
um who can change
um greater angle is a greater angle
angry Waters operations would be
enormously beneficial I think
um so for that reason I'm happy to to
support
um the motion and perhaps if I can ask
the chair whether the president would
agree with my suggestions if so I won't
propose that as a full Amendment but I
think it's an important consideration
um looked at the proposer nod the second
nod yeah okay thank you and um next to
speak is councilor Stringer
I've represented uh the village of
mendelsham for almost two decades and
it's the source of uh many good things
is mentioned and I remember uh uh one
day throwing leaves through people's
doors whether they wanted them or not
and a lovely gentleman conventional
green called Mr Alban said I want to
show you something uh okay
um and we walked up a little footpath to
where there's this quite large ditch in
the middle of nowhere and I'm thinking
is this it is this the shovel around the
back of the head and I'm being left dead
in that age and it wasn't and and what
he pointed to at the bottom of the ditch
he said what do you see when you look
down at that ditch I said well hang on a
minute the water's running in two
different directions and he said yeah
that way is the source of the river Dove
and that way is the source of the river
giving
is the source of Two Rivers and I found
it absolutely fascinating a lot of
history when someone had actually had
barges coming all the way up from The
Stone Market apparently up to membership
phenomenal
so water and particularly water quality
is something that if you take incredibly
seriously and there are many
frustrations in development control uh
some are get over a book some aren't but
I think the issue of of water and sewage
capacity is one of those ones that then
does the public think that we have a lot
of authority over this
uh well in fact we don't and it's mostly
because the utility is privatized I'm
not going to re-rehearse the arguments
of privatization but what's stepped down
in that statute probably should have
been a tad tighter than it is at the
moment because what we end up going
through at development control often is
what I call an absolute charade uh and
case in point was committee a committee
B rather back in September where there
were four items three of which had the
same response from Anglia water and I'll
read out the response there's a
development in Middleton
and it says the foul drainage from this
development is in the catchment of Stone
Market water recycling center which
currently does not have the capacity
treat the flows from the development
site Anglia water are obligated to
accept the foul flows from the
development with the benefit of planning
consent and would therefore take the
necessary steps to ensure there is
sufficient treatment capacity should the
planning Authority Grant permission
that's a statement of the law that's
actually not at all helpful what we want
to know is if we connect this up will
this mean that more raw sewage events in
our river system will take place or not
that's actually all we really need to
know because we need to out that almost
glossing over and not answering the
direct question in supporting this
motion I think it will it will it will
help us do that and I don't want to lay
the blame all at Anglia Watts door part
of the legislation and how we've stacked
it up in this country there's almost a
perverse incentive for a water company
to reach a gold standard on this because
if you try and invest money to hit the
gold standard you don't get and if you
don't hit that gold standard you don't
get any money at all from government so
you can invest in in upping the water
quality invest an awful lot of money and
not get any uh repayment from government
unless you hit that very very gold
standard I think we need to sort of look
at changing that legislation so if you
improve it you you get almost a sliding
scale of Grant from government to assist
in actually making it better than it is
at the moment but I think this will be a
very very small step in getting some
light shown onto this area so that
people have Clarity is what our role is
as a planning Authority and that we're
doing everything we possibly can to
mitigate more sewage outfall events in
our Rivers because the treatment
capacity is a legal obligation of the
water company thank you
thank you very much and um if you'd um
mind indulging me for a moment I'd just
like to um say a few words on this issue
um as the drainage board member for
mid-suffer can also the vice chair of
the Suffolk flood risk scrutiny
committee that councilor Fleming was
talking about
um we started looking into this issue
quite a long time ago maybe a year ago
just before it became a big issue in the
within the public
um
I was absolutely shocked by the size of
this issue how much we would have to
spend to um fix it but I do believe it's
fixable one of the really shocking
things is just a hundred meters or more
away from this very chamber there's an
outflow that regularly or is a pump
sewage into the river as well as many
other all over RM District but um the um
and also being a farmer agriculture is
also another
um big
polluter of the rivers so um it I think
the um
I think councilor Fleming has sold
herself short though on what she said
with her um when when she seconded the
emotion because she's um she's done a
huge amount in the Suffolk flood risk
scrutiny committee to get together a
stakeholder meeting
um of the rivers trust Anglia water
um the environment agency Suffolk County
Council and many other people to look
into this and we we had a um a day of
discussing these issues and two of the
main issues were to do with these um
sewage outflows she also um
was put a letter in to the minister on
this which I was very proud to um sign
as well which um was talking about
removing this some section three which
is the the right to uh put sewage into
the Watercourse from developments
um and um we we had a very positive
response
from that letter um so um
the the thing about it is while I've
been on this Council I've seen issues in
pressing field and um whirlingworth
where we've got serious problems with
outflows
um something needs to change and it does
seem like the um wheels are in motion to
make that change
um the um
so yeah I I completely support this
motion I think it's a really good motion
for this um Council to make and um thank
you very much
next will be councilor Byrne
and
I'm very happy to support
any
um action which draws attention to the
inadequacies of the sewage system
um
partly because uh I suffer from those
inadequacies myself in the sense that
although I know we're talking here about
outflows into the
um enter the drainage systems uh into
the rivers and streams
um
inadequacies of the system the sewage
system also also affect outflows onto
onto the ground we just happen to live
at the end of um
the whole of medicine and and the
axley's sewage system and uh before
where the lowest point in that system
before it shoots across the fields to to
uh the eye treatment plant and that uh
that pipe that takes it across those
fields is just six inches in diameter
for the whole of that uh for the whole
of that uh population
so um although it's not directly
concerned with what you're talking about
this evening it's very much indirectly
concerned with it and I do support the
the most
thank you
thank you thank you very much accounts
the scarf
you sure um
well item one asked for
a care of the streets for me to invite
senior officers of the relevant bodies
which you can all read for yourself I
think this really does
bring to bring the issue to light
because I think sometimes uh
representatives from these various
bodies don't get the questioning perhaps
that they might deserve and I think it
bringing a spotlight on it by bringing
it to scrutiny committee because it has
the power to look at anything that
affects our residents actually might
make them a little bit more aware of the
issues I also think support for
changes to the law and lobbying for that
whether it be for our local MPS whether
it be for the government minister is
something that should and all councils
within the country should be doing
because it's a it's a disgrace in this
day and age that we're actually pumping
sewage water into the real courses is to
disgrace that we pump it right into the
ocean as well and there are many cases
of that we saw a TV event I think it was
in Cornwall the other week where the
water was looking
going into a lovely part of the Cornish
Coastline so anything we can do I think
as members whether it's through the
screening committee members of this
Council to highlight the issue and keep
the issue at the top of the agenda I
think it has to be supported so I'll
certainly be supporting the motion
thank you councilor geek
a small step but it's a symbolic one in
the right direction and it was really
heartening to hear councilor Fleming
talking about designating some River
bathing sites there are several good
ones to choose from but all are
currently affected by sewage discharges
the elmswell sewage discharge that flows
into the Blackboard North and it's
joined by the badwell ash sewage
discharge coming West Via that tiny
little stream which was really not very
much
at all through Langham and hunston and
those combined discharges then run
through the Suffolk wildlife's trust
Wildlife trusts Nature Reserve at
michaelmir with its otters and birds and
bird watchers to sappistan and the
Blackburn at sappistan is incredibly
picturesque and that's where I normally
swim and I am not alone in in swimming
in suffolks rivers wild Suffolk swimmers
has over 800 people on its mailing list
the Suffolk blue tits cold water
swimmers have over a thousand people
they both run several swims every week
all through the year and perhaps I've
just thought maybe we should invite our
MPS to join us at this the Stoneham
aspel discharge that flows Southwest
through the Suffolk County Council owned
local nature reserve of fen Alder car
increasing Saint Peter and that joins
the River gipping just north of Needham
Market people swim a little bit further
down the gipping at Needham where
there's a pool with a rope swing near
the lake but the most popular place of
all is bromford while Suffolk swimmers
there can only really swim in the early
mornings because later in the day it's
often too busy it has families paddling
teenagers jumping off the bridge there
are also kayakers paddle boarders and
Rowing dinghies there it's an incredibly
well used free resource there's a huge
asset to our whole Community it's good
for physical and mental health and it
also of course helps people value their
natural environment but people don't
want to use the rivers they don't want
to get in the rivers if they're heard
that if they've heard that they're
dangerous and they certainly don't want
to use them if they smell bad as they
can do at present and it's taken decades
you know really all my life to be able
to swim in rivers because they've been
recovering after
and Industrial spillages of the 20th
century and really let's not endanger
that recovery now let's do everything we
can let's take even if it is a small
step I'm I'm really thrilled that um
that this um this motion has has got a
cross-chamber support
thank you very much councilor Morley
thank you chair
um
one of my residents has been subject to
some of these nasty stuff
so I've first-hand experience where a
discharge
I believe from one of the sites in
that's actually referenced in the table
um
caused by inadequate treatment plants
being placed in which meant that the
Overflow went into the ditch which then
went into his fish pond which then
killed all his his fish flooded his
garden and left raw sewage flying around
in his garden
pretty disgusting really so I I have
every attention of supporting this and I
don't want to amend the motion but I
would just like to ask the chair of
scrutiny when they actually start to
look at this in more detail it's not
just anglian water that may be causing
this there are private sites around
where who are contributing to this great
disgraceful situation and I would just
like to ask that you consider those in
your deliberations thank you
thank you very much is anyone waiting
Council Pratt
thank you Chad yeah I just wanted to say
that I was really um excited
um by by when this when this motion was
submitted
um and and I totally agree with it I
think one one thing to reflect upon is
the reason that this motion is really
really important
um is is of course the the sort of
Health and Social benefits that our
waterways can can give us
um but but also the the environmental
um the environmental importance of of
our Rivers wetlands and an estuaries as
well
um if these ecosystems are subjected to
Chronic and high levels of pollutants
and and nutrients
um coming out of the sewage system it
sort of it can eventually lead to to
like a Tipping Point in some
circumstances we go from species Rich
ecosystems that are often dominated
um by um
by aquatic plants and so on
um to to A system that is less diverse
less species Rich often dominated by by
algae and it's quite difficult once
you've crossed that threshold into that
alternative State it's sometimes quite
difficult to bring it back
um you know the the Norfolk boards being
a really Splendid example
um in some cases although there are
efforts to restore some of those broads
back to their sort of former glory
um so so really it's really important it
doesn't just reduce biodiversity but it
also impairs these ecosystems to carry
out their incredibly important functions
things like water filtration processing
of nutrients sequestration of carbon in
terms of wetlands and estuaries as well
in fact in some rivers around the world
scientists uh have pointed out that
there are vast areas in the coastal
ocean which um are kind of termed as
dead zones ecological dead zones because
um there are vast areas
um where the sediments in the ocean bed
and the water
um
the the water column has just been
totally deoxygenated and very few and
very little life can can survive in
these places of course that's
detrimental to fisheries and everything
so so this is all you know there are
many sort of links
um and and it is a and it is a complex
problem I just wanted to touch on one
thing I feel
um the councilor Caston has
um you know sort of almost permittedly
to touch on this now
um but it's not just um it's not just
sewage treatment plants I know that
that's what we're just debating in this
motion the river y has had many many
case studies over the last couple of
years
um some instigated by the journalist
George Mondeo
um and um they've they've found that
whilst the river Y is subjected to to
really high levels of sewage outflows
and pollution from that Source
nutrient levels originating from high
density chicken farms
outstrip the contributions to pollution
from
um
sewage outflows
um so I think I I also sort of have to
just Justin's observation or a point of
notepad I'm really sorry but you're over
your three minutes but I'm really
enjoying your technical detail I just I
just wanted to just make one
so we could have more stringent
process when it comes to
assuming like chicken factories that
could contribute to this problem thank
you
thank you very much
um councilor field
thank you General I'll repeat all the
points that I really agree with
certainly going to support this motion I
I was just to say the uh the parish
councilors at bramford has used to
bend my ear aimlessly about the amount
of swimming that went off on off the
bridge there as as being pointed out and
the interesting thing is that they used
to say they did it as a young Lads so
it's not something that's occurred over
the last year or two or decade or two or
it's a long-term exercise
and I totally welcome the effort to put
some pressure on anglian water to
improve their investment in their
business basically
and I can point out that if you look at
the number of discharge events on on the
top line of this uh report
108 is once every three and a half days
is that really an emergency discharge
you know I mean my measure it rains
quite frequently at part times of the
year like now but it doesn't reach
emergency levels once every three and a
half days
and if you look at the times of
discharge that's 18 hours on average per
discharge
so they clearly have a major problem
here that needs addressing
it might be chicken farms as you just
heard but whatever it is there is a
clear need to clean water out
for the benefit of all of us and for the
benefit of the environment and it is
just not being done
so any effort we can make to bring some
pressure to some publicize this to make
the management teams in those Industries
respond is is to me totally welcome so I
certainly will be supporting this thank
you
thank you very much
um and councilor Carter and then I think
we'll um sum up the debate thank you
I chose it wrong to come at the end when
councilor Pratt and Council of field
tender Knights concise arguments and I
tend to practice and get in the muddle
so I try to keep it below every three
minutes
um
I will have to say that I always do feel
quite irked when I see Anglia water
mentioned on a planning film because
it has as well been it I believe it's
been recorded by the environment agency
as requiring significant improvements
um not only for the Overflow but also
for the uh I believe it was a 170 Mega
liters of water per day from pipes the
loss well that's actually quite a
minimum number from other companies
um
and I do have to say after hearing
reports from a council a geek about uh
for wild swimming little bit of
pettiness someone apart not one to
support because I can't swim anymore but
other than that
um
but we are here today because we have a
a responsibility to our residents we
have a responsibility to actually say to
be aware of what's going on aware of
even if we haven't got behavioral
control over it but we have to say but
we are aware we have seen this we
support and we are looking out for you
and if we are aware of this situation by
all means we must say something about it
and this is a perfect Forum this is a
perfect way of going ahead about it so I
am really pleased to hear all the
reports from across the Chamber of
people supporting this motion and even
this is a perfect case to start
there are other issues but we are aware
of we are other issues but we haven't
got the overall say over but we can
still make a statement we can still say
not just in planning but there's other
planning issues but we can still say
we've noticed this we're picking up on
it
people need to start getting their act
together and we're watching them do so
so this is the prime candidate for it
and so I'm in full support of this
motion and I hope we use this as a
example as a starting point to actually
look at other issues as well not just
water and say but we're aware we keep an
eye out and we will support our
residents so thank you
thank you
I think councilor War boys had his hand
up before when I when I said that we get
we'd summarize the councilor wall boys
and then we'll go to summaries
thank you Jerry I started to wave when
you said you were about to summarize
um
yes I think um
a few things one is I think looking
forward to the senior office of Anglia
water coming forward to be scrutinized
uh we shouldn't have any problem with
their attendance
um of what has actually given
ugly water and aerating for customer
engagement
uh that's the only a rate to Anglia
awards has got
the environment agency gives it a
two-star rating it's the third highest
rate of total pollution incidence
and a quarter of serious pollution
incidents and this is a huge problem for
Anglia water they do recognize they put
forward in their in their defense
that there are most acute issues in its
region
it's the largest in area of all the
water companies
climatic change population housing
growth and the need to protect and
enhance the natural environment it
doesn't actually mention mixing sewage
and storm Waters
um so I think they would be only too
Keen to come forward and publicly defend
their position
they have recently been fined 8.3
million pounds for missing Targets on
pollution flooding and base Mains that
sounds like a significant amount it's
about eight percent of their dividends
85 percent of their dividends go
overseas
it's
a public company
but it's privately owned it's owned by a
Consortium of international pension and
private Equity Funds and it's registered
in Jersey and I think that is where we
are going to struggle to get off work to
seriously invest in its local
infrastructure until there is a
significant change in legislation which
makes it a material
um
issue in planning and development we're
not going to get that kind of
change we need from them but I think we
need to bring Anglia water to publicly
defend their position and to account for
specific issues thank you
I am supporting the motion
thank you very much and councilor
Fleming seconded this do you wish to say
anything at this point
well thank you thank you very much well
I learned so much because there's so
much has been said
but I just I think this is obviously a
very complex situation cleaning up our
Waters is terribly important I'm a wild
swimmer myself but I am I tend to go to
the Sea rather than Rivers
um actually I feel it's a little bit
little bit safer I mean I I think
um
going back to what we can do it looks as
if you know planning is our tool
um for the most part
um but I think also it's clearly a
health and well-being issue and I think
maybe our health and well-being strategy
and our approach to
use of public open spaces you know we
need to include possibly water and
rivers as part of our Open Space
strategy
um it is whether it's formally publicly
accessible or not the public accesses it
and uses it to their benefit and I think
that may be an area we can
bring in a bit more clout but I think
until we get that full implementation of
the Water Management Act of 2010
um
we are limited and we must must push for
that and I think we're close now and we
also
you know defra is a big
um player here not so much for sewerage
treatment but for farming because defra
determines what rates pesticides and
fertilizers are applied at along with
the manufacturers of them and farmers
will apply
according to the directions
um other directions properly risk
assessed for
um their biodiversity impacts their
bioaccumulative effects as the chemicals
go into the waterways are taken up by
various organisms and by a concentrated
again into the food chain I'm not
confident that all that is happening as
as well as we would like but anyway I'm
so glad for full support in the chamber
thank you very much and this drew our
small bit thank you
thank you very much councilman would you
like to
add anything
yeah thank you chair and um very
grateful for all the contributions I
won't say much I think there's still a
chance of getting home for the second
half of the Brazil game
um
but uh I'm very happy to take councilor
Richardson's suggestion that we write to
I think it was off what you suggested I
don't know if we need to formalize that
in the motion or whether we just sort of
take that as a agreed
yeah I'll take that as agreed yeah thank
you okay yeah no issues in the chamber
yeah we'll take that as agreed
um I think we this this motion uh
attempts to leverage the little bit of
power that we have uh uh in in planning
to maybe shine a spotlight on this area
I sense that there's a frustration that
we can't do more but this is what we can
do and I'm very glad for the cross-party
support
um can I just finish in a slightly
unusual Way by recommending a book it's
a book that was written by a mid-suffolk
resident sadly no longer with us a man
called Roger Deacon who lived in uh
councilor War boys
Ward malice a book called waterlog
reading that book opened my eyes to the
issues of around water around wild
swimming very much the sort of Bible for
wild swimmers I recommend reading it and
I recommend you supporting this motion
thank you chair
thank you very much so we'll um we'll
take that to the boat now
I will ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
an electronic debate I think thank you
chair that vote is now open for
councilors to cost a vote
that's Pratt
can I take your vote then
chair that is unanimous that is 27 votes
for
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much and so that's
carried and I'm now the next meeting is
on Thursday the 26th of January at the
normal 5 30 p.m and I'll finish this
meeting at six minutes past seven thank
you